♪
STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
ONE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT MAJORS
WENT VIRAL THIS WEEK.
>> MAYOR GARCETTI AND GAVIN
NEWSOM IS RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERY
SINGLE PERSON THAT DOES NOT HAVE
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DOES NOT HAVE A
JOB AND ALL THE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE GOING UNDER AND WE NEED YOUR
HELP.
WE NEED SOMEBODY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS.
STEVE: JOINING ME NOW IS THE
OWNER OF PINEAPPLE HILL SALOON
AND GRILL IN SHERMAN OAKS,
CALIFORNIA, ANGELA MARSDEN BIRD
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US BUT
MOST OF ALL FOR THAT INCREDIBLE
VIDEO.
I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU I NEVER
WATCHED ANYTHING RELATED TO A
STORY IN THE NEWS THAT HAD A
GREATER EMOTIONAL IMPACT ON ME
THAN WATCHING YOUR VIDEO.
FOR THOSE THAT HAVE NOT SEEN IT
JUST TELL US YOUR STORY.
>> I MEAN, THE DAY THAT I DID
THAT VIDEO BASICALLY THEY
STARTED THE LOCKDOWN WELL, THEY
CLOSED OUTDOOR DINING TWO DAYS
BEFORE THANKS GIVING WITHOUT ANY
NOTICE SO OUR LAST NIGHT WAS THE
NIGHT BEFORE THANKS GIVING AND I
HAD TO TELL MY STAFF THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO STAY OPEN FOR
TAKEOUT BUT I LOSE SO MUCH MONEY
DOING IT THAT IF I DID THAT I
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO EVER REOPEN
AGAIN SO I HAD TO SHUT DOWN.
THAT FRIDAY I WAS COMING IN TO
GIVE LAST PAYCHEX AND WE HAD
TAKEN WHAT FOOD WOULD GO BAD AND
PUT IN GROCERY BAGS FOR THE
STAFF.
I ALSO HAD DECIDED, IRONICALLY,
THE WEEK BEFORE THAT I WAS NOT
GOING TO BE AFRAID AND GOING TO
START SPEAKING OUT SO I WAS
TRYING TO PLAN A PROTEST AND I
CAME IN TO MY PARKING LOT AND
THERE WERE MY, YOU KNOW,  WHEN I
COME IN THE BACK IT WAS VERY
SURREAL BECAUSE OR SHOCKING I
HAVE MY PATIO THAT I HAVE SPENT,
I’M LIVING OFF LOAN MONEY,
SITTING THERE SHUTTERED AND THEN
RIGHT THERE IN THE SAME PARKING
LOT WITHIN 20 STEPS WAS THE SAME
EXACT --.
STEVE: WHERE SHOWING THAT RIGHT
NOW.
>> YEAH, THE SAME SET UP FOR A
MOVIE CREW TO EAT LUNCH AND
STUFF CATERING TRUCKS AND, A
TENT FOR TWO HUNTER PEOPLE IT
SEEMED LIKE TO ME AND I DON’T
KNOW BUT AND I WAS IN SHOCK.
I WENT IN TO MY RESTAURANT AND
WAS LIKE TRYING TO STAY FOCUSED
TO GET THINGS TOGETHER AND I
JUST BROKE DOWN CRYING AND THEN
I GOT ANGRY AND SAID I HAVE TO
TELL THE TRUTH.
I MEAN, AS BUSINESS OWNERS WE
ARE AFRAID TO SAY ANYTHING
BECAUSE WE ARE AFRAID TO BE
TAKEN LIKE WE DON’T CARE ABOUT
PEOPLE IF WE STAY OPEN OR WE ARE
JUST WORRIED ABOUT US BUT YOU
KNOW,  I HAVE TEN PEOPLE WORKING
FOR ME BUT I HAD TO TELL THEY
HAVE NO JOB RIGHT BEFORE
CHRISTMAS WITH NO NOTICE.
I JUST SAID TO MY FRIENDS WHO
WERE THERE THAT I’VE GOT TO FILL
THIS AND LET THE WORLD SEE IT.
I GOT PEOPLE HAVE TO KNOW THE
HYPOCRISY OF WHAT IS GOING ON
AND IT MAKES NO SENSE.
STEVE: EXACTLY.
NONE OF IT MAKES SENSE AND THE
OTHER POINT IS THIS, JUST LIKE
SO MANY SMALL BUSINESSES YOU
HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE AND YOU
PUT IN THE INVESTMENT SO THAT
YOU COULD BE OPEN WITHOUT DOOR
DINING AND DO IT IN A SAFE
MANNER AND YOU’VE DONE ALL THE
THINGS WE WOULD WANT PEOPLE TO
DO AND STILL THEY CRUSH YOU.
IT’S SO AN RATING.
ANGELA, I SAW THE MAYOR ERIC
CASSIDY PUT OUT A STATEMENT
SAYING HE’S HEART GOES OUT TO
YOU BUT HE STILL GOING TO KEEP
YOU SHUT DOWN.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE AND WHAT
YOU WANT TO SAY TO HIM?
>> YOU KNOW, I MEAN, WHAT I
WANT TO SAY TO HIM IS THAT AS
BUSINESS OWNERS WE HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING YOU WANTED AND WE
WILL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES TO
KEEP OUR PEOPLE SAFE.
WE KNOW COVID IS OUT THERE BUT
YOU ARE LIVING IN LALA LAND IF
YOU THINK THE REST OF US, THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND THE LOWER
MIDDLE-CLASS CAN ACTUALLY STAY
AT HOME.
WE ARE -- I HAVE A SINGLE MOM
WITH A CHILD WHO CAN’T PAY HER
RENT.
I’VE GOT ANOTHER NEW HIRE
BECAUSE WE GOT BUSY IN OCTOBER
WITH THE PATIO AND IT LOOKED
LIKE THINGS WOULD TURN AROUND
WHO IS COUCH SURFING BECAUSE SHE
NO LONGER HAS AN APARTMENT AND
ARE ON A PLUM AND HAS RUN OUT.
IT IS RIDICULOUS AND AS
POLITICIANS OR A MAYOR OF THE
CITY IT IS YOUR JOB TO LOOK AT
RISK ASSESSMENT AND TO DO, THE
GENTLEMAN YOU JUST HAD ON WAS
BRILLIANT.
COULD HE TALK TO MAYOR GARCETTI?
THE DECISIONS THAT ARE BEING
MADE MAKE NO SENSE AND EVERLY
HILL THEIR COUNCIL VOTED TO KEEP
IT, PASADENA OPEN AND THE
SHERIFF WHAT A WONDERFUL SHERIFF
TO SAY HE WOULD NOT ENFORCE IT
BUT YOU KNOW,  THEY ARE 13
INTAKE LICENSE AND HEALTH
PERMITS AWAY IF WE DEFY IT IN
OPEN SO WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO
DO?
HOW ARE WE GOING TO EAT?
HOW WILL WE KEEP A ROOF OVER OUR
HEADS?
LIKE YOU SAID, THE SUICIDE RATE,
YOU KNOW,  THE SINGLE MOM WITH
THE CHILD CAN’T PAY HER RENT AND
I SAID I WOULD DO EVERYTHING I
CAN TO SEE IF I CAN FIND TO WORK
AND SHE SAID ANGELA, ALL I KNOW
HOW TO DO IS BARTEND OR WAIT
TABLES AND I SAID WHAT HAVE YOU
BEEN DOING AND SHE’S LIKE WELL
IT’S DISGUSTING.
>> SHE SAID SHE’S BEEN ON
ANTIDEPRESSANTS BUT SHE DOESN’T
NEED PILL, SHE NEEDS A JOB.
STEVE: THIS IS SO OUTRAGEOUS ON
AS THEY PRAYED I GOT TO SAY
THANK YOU, ANGELA FOR SPEAKING
OUT.
I WANT TO STAY IN TOUCH WITH YOU
BECAUSE YOU’RE SUCH A POWERFUL
VOICE AND YOU ARE REALLY LEADING
THE RESISTANCE TO ALL OF THIS.
WE’VE GOT TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST
THIS BECAUSE THEIR RULES MAKE NO
SENSE AND THEIR RIDICULOUS AND
THEY’RE NOT BASED ON SCIENCE AND
IT’S COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE AND
WE SHOULD NOT ACCEPT IT.
I’M SORRY BUT WE GOT TO GO NOW
ANGELA BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU